Welcome back to Minecraft part 4, gaming week. I was mining my house
Okay
I was building this thing and I'm placing a stairs and I see this guy
Who is that? What the frick are you?
Go away! Hello?
Get off my property, I have a gun. Maybe he's a friend. I don't want to be racist
Hello? He killed a fish!
Hello? Hello, I'm talking to you. Oh jeez you're creepy. Oh God.
(9 year olds):
"Minecraft isn't scary, Felix". (*Clears Throat*) Okay.
Dude, we can be friends. Hey you want melon?
Do you like this?
Oh, look at this he like it. What are you doing with that block? Hey, hey put that block down! Put that block that do-
Goddammit! Put it down. Put it down. Put it down! Put it down!
Where are you going?
My god, there's endermens everywhere. I have to kill them. All right, do I kill endermen?
He just farted!
(Screams of terror)
I'M SORRY
The melon! Hey, melon, take it!
Aah! Jesus!
What the frick dude, that was so scary!
You better not steal my stuff dude.
We're cool.
It's all good. Just like nothing happened. All right, you just all right. I'll stick to what I'm doing
You stick to what you're doing and no more melon from now on
The audacity of some people. Okay. So basically I built this indoor pool.
It's pretty sweet. It lights up at dark
And uh, I'm like building the house. Just making it nice
Making it cool. It's gonna like, you know, be a thing. It's gonna I'm gonna live here
actually, there's one thing I been wanting to do cuz when when I started playing Minecraft
The the bed was automatically red. That's how I remember Minecraft, but now they have dye and stuff
so I think if I do this
and this
WOW
It's a red bed! Now I feel at home. Now I can sleep at night. There it is. That's what I remember
Oh, that takes me back. You wake up to burning zombies. That's what I like
That's what I like to see. I haven't finished this because I want to fish
So we I want to have I want to have actual fishes in my house
I want like the stars and this night and everything to be epic.
No! I only have one string god damnit what drops strings? Do spiders drop strings?
I'm sorry. Mr. Spy there you have to die
Yes, ha ha Oh
Also, by the way, oh, yeah don't jump on the crotch. Everyone lost their mind lysippos. Oh, I am learning as I'm going, okay
No, I'm not a Minecraft veteran yet
We're going for the ender dragon
Snaggin what was I doing? I already forgot. Yes a fishing rod. That's what we're doing
I know how to make it in by hand
But just so you guys learn I'm making a fishing rod then of course, we need a boat, right?
both time
Both time. Sorry Jurgen. You can't come with me. What's the grass not growing? All right, doesn't matter. It's both time
Damn I'm fast. Oh
Yeah. Oh, yeah
That's what I'm talking dude. That's a fish right there. That's a fish right there. Here we go. Bros. Here we go
Come on come on grab it. Come on grab it
Come on you want it don't need a bait on the fish. Don't laugh at me. You're again. I'm trying here
Do I need a bait for it? I probably need a bait for it. Could I actually just capture him with my bucket?
This is how we fish in Sweden with buckets
Come here, man
Come here, man. Come here. Come here. Come here. Come here. Come here
Tactical fishing haters said it wasn't possible
But I got a bucket of fish now you go in there, oh my god, I got a bucket of
What where he got again, my friend we gotta get him a friend Bros
Technically you're supposed to row a boat backwards
So this game isn't that historically accurate after all? Okay. All right, we're going scuba diving
Can you make scuba diving equipment in this what the hell just happened?
god, I'm
God I'm
God it's scary down there. No, I'm not scared of everything in Minecraft. Okay, you know what? Let's just make a bunch of buckets
I don't have time for this
It's bucket making time smash like if you're excited for bucket making time. That's what I thought. That's what I thought
All right, we're making but that's what I thought. That's what I thought. All right, we're making buckets. I
Got a bucket full of bucket full of sunshine
Jesus Christ what is happening?
Or you can drown in Minecraft
That's so unrealistic
Commit god. Damn. Why can the fishes breathe underwater then, huh?
Explain that liberals. Let's try and find more exotic fishes
You are Oh God. Everything is scary in this game. Come back here
God damn, they're too fast squeezies
Come on
All right, you're too ugly yesterday, I'm sorry
Those are the Minecraft rules don't look at me. I don't make it up your ugly you die
You're coming with me in the bucket right now, I don't come in the bucket. All right in the boat then fine
No, I want my turtle in my house
Can we drown the people Oh
Kitty, kitty, you're going in the bucket get it. You're going in the bucket. You have no saying kitty your dog in the bucket
You're going in the bucket. Come here you snake
God, damn it
so
Disrespectful what's happening? Hello
How's he doing?
Dude, you got so much bread, bro. Yes, you know mine do you?
Go I'll sleep in his house
Have you been looking at me the whole night?
Well, sorry I thought it was my house
What I can make dyed pants what leather? Okay, six leather. I'll be right back
cartography table
All right, well this pool idea is very underwhelming
Why are they old there?
Is it the draft in the water? All right, it's cow murdering time Peter. I have to do it. I have to get emerald
I have to get dyed pants. All right, you gonna die
You didn't even drop leather. You're useless. They're escaping. They're escaping
They were escaping the camp
No, they're all this gay Bank. What the god? Damn it you are you and you're dead. You're dead. You're just dead
That's what happened. No one escapes my camp
All right one gets to live because he's good. You escape you die. That's the rules well
You're all there you suck dude, I will now we can get an epic pants. At least now we can get the Gucci pants
Hey, come on, did I tell you to stop?
You the Gucci pants guy. There you are six. I need six. Are you crazy? Oh
My god, dude, let's let's bounce uragan. These people are trying to swindle us
Alright, well this works out because I actually wanted to just ride out and murder people
I haven't really explored the area although oh wait, actually, I forgot. I want to make a comp s. Can you make a compass?
I remember making a compound even back in my day. I don't want to get lost. I don't want to lose my epic house
Boom boom boom and then in the middle. There's my compact. Alright, we're going out on an adventure
Oh
It tells you where the house is
That's so nice. Stop. Stop resisting stop
resisting
We got six. Okay, no more killing. We only reap what we sow that is not how that expression marks. Okay?
Well, I feel a lot more confident just riding off seeing what we're gonna find
You know I'm saying like who knows what we're gonna find
Like a little hole. That's pretty cool. Actually. I do need coal. Hold on. Hold up once a
Your again
Again
Yeah again, where is here again
Where's here again again, it's getting dark. Yeah again when
You're again
He must be here somewhere Oh
God
Hello. Have you seen her again? Oh God, big one help me. I looked away one second, and then he was gone
Have you seen Jurgen? Oh my god. He must have fallen down the hole or something. He must be so scared. Oh
God no, I was hoping he maybe he ran back home
Scared chicken. Oh
So happy, oh I'll never leave you again here again, whoa Jesus
almost fell down there
My god
It's dangerous this game. Whoa, what a mountain
Well, what is that
The shipwreck
What is that? All right, you're gonna stay here
Gonna make sure it's safe
What kind of wood is this
Is that a treasure chest oh
My god
Minecraft oh
My crack paper
Hey you're again
God, dammit. Why does he keep like stay yet Oh
God not this again. I left him here. Oh
I hear him. You snake where are you sir? Way to get a whistle to get your horse to again. Oh
My god, I look so pimp I have less armor, but I look cool so it's okay
Why do I hear him but not see him
What?
What the hell is this?
Have you kidnapped Jurgen?
Hey
What the hell are you? You tried to kill me. I'll kill you
It's a crossbow you should wait too slow bro
Cool it's getting dark again. The Jurgen is nowhere to be found. Hey look more enemy flowers. I know I
Hear them here. They are not here. Explain my oh
My god
What the hell are you wearing?
What is this?
They must have captured your again give them back to me
Jurgen are you in here?
There again, I hear you. I
Hear you you seen the trees or some shit. Oh
My
Why do I feel like I'm going crazy where
This yard again
The thing is I hear you
The ghost of Jurgen is haunting me I swear to God
It was my only friend
Now I can't find him I
Looked away two seconds
And then he was just gone just
Like that
Where oh my God, where were it do keep disappearing it? Oh
Alright we have him back. I looked all night literally all night. I
Don't know what you were doing and I'm not even gonna ask
Going back home here again
What the hell is that got a donkey gonna come with me donkey
You want someone weak
Are you kidding me? Are you kidding me? Are you kidding me? Are you kidding me?
Yeah, yeah